racontez nous votre histoire commença
donc je faisais la stac bonsoir et
c'était le dernier prime mais on avait
quand même des grosses grosses vedettes
galecki bruno mars
nos marques sur mars
mais
alors oui et donc est en fait moi
j'avais une très grande loge la loge de
l'animateur et du pardon j'étais
animateur et lui reste à l'écouté et y
avait un toilette commun pour les deux
non il va aux toilettes je peux pas vous
n'aurez rien et j'attends il paraît
qu'ils démarrent dès mai qui sort des
toilettes et là c'est une infection
n'ont jamais vu ça de ma vie
et du coup c'est horrible parce que ça
m'a cassé le personnage aubry ce que je
fais ça il est venu chanter après à côté
de moi tout je ne voyais pas le chanteur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais qui avait fait condamner un chiotte
pendant un quart d'heure c'est horrible
à m